hammerlos für service parat sie ist es
genauso wird für hessen plant zum
händler und denke ich muss meinen kopf
schäfer gefühl die mannschaft könne
vektoren da sein sie können ja und das
mache jetzt noch in der situation als
sie kann jetzt nehmen sie hüllen oder so
aber es wird sicher der moment
annemieke burgmüller konnte nur das
nötigste retten bettwäsche und ein paar
andere habseligkeiten dass es irgendwann
so weit kommen könnte dass sie ihr haus
fluchtartig verlassen muss und nie mehr
zurück kann das wusste sie und doch
haben sie die naturgewalten in ihrem
innersten erschüttert
[Musik]
wo sind sie muss ihr und richtet
entstanden haben bis zum mittag ist
heike makatsch nicola ihm fertig und
tencent schülerchor ob sie könig heiko
locken sie mal dahin sandisk amt habe
mir die filme zeigt die natur krass es
geschah am mittwoch dem 23
august 2017 um 9 uhr 30 im bündnerischen
berger vom kitzinger lösten sich drei
millionen kubikmeter fels und donnerten
richtung tal
[Musik]
dies führte zu einem uhr gang entlang
der bundes k
[Musik]
das 200 seelen dorf bondo musste
vollständig evakuiert werden
[Musik]
seither wohnen rettung müller und seine
frau in einer ferienwohnung im
nahegelegenen soli vorerst gemietet für
einen monat
es ist glimpflich abgelaufen
das ganze noch im ficc 40 kritiker wird
dass sie danach passiert bei uns dass
ich noch wenig sie für mini und mini
fantasie zwei tage später am nachmittag
des 25
august kam es zu einem weiteren
felsabbruch und erneuter muren bewegung
auch das hatten die einheimischen kommen
sehen
geologen hatten seit langem davor
gewarnt dass millionen kubikmeter fels
abzubrechen drohten
[Musik]
ich halte fest irgendwann kommt es dass
ich wieder kranke psyche wie sie hatten
das immer im kopf gehabt und meine frau
hat auf seite die übertreiber aber jetzt
ist das ist ja eigentlich ein bittere
lektion sie zugesichert sie persönliches
dünte komisch an electric wieso will
jetzt mit begriff war das heißt alle
begriffen dass man bis muss machbar
obwohl man hätte bis macht anne frank
weg ist das hat aber nicht lang mit
fünfeinhalb millionen franken wurden
investiert um besagtes auffangbecken zu
errichten 2015 weiß fertig und sollte
die bewohner bongos ruhiger schlafen
lassen der pizzaiolo war nämlich schon
lange hin stabil
immer wieder kam es in den letzten 100
jahren zu berg stürzen letztmals am 27
dezember 2011 rund zwei millionen
kubikmeter kamen damals runter für
marcello nigrin ideen verantwortlichen
für natur und gefahren schutz war klar
dass man etwas unternehmen musste damals
erklärte er dem rätoromanischen
fernsehen die lage alles was grün sei
sei stabil
das rote gebiet seien bewegt der cembalo
wurde fortan mit rat tat beobachtet
zudem wurde eingangs der wahl bonn das
kein alarmsystem installiert bestehend
aus zug seilen und radar
entsteht auf den säulen zug wird ein
alarm ausgelöst
alle lichtsignale in der umgebung von
gondo und promo wechseln auf rot die
straßen werden gesperrt
jetzt zwei jahre später treffen wir eine
gewinne wieder das überwachungssystem
dass er damals vorgestellt hatte hat
sich bewährt
rondo konnte dank dieser installation
vollständig evakuiert werden
eigentlich erwartet ja aber das ist
natürlich natur und man kann nicht alles
ablesen was genau was hinter amberg
stadt oder den befehl dringlich neben
der naturgewalt überraschte die
verantwortlichen auch das enorme
medieninteresse
anfangs gab die gemeindepräsidentin noch
persönlich auskunft
[Musik]
bald wurde ihr der rummel zu viel
die gemeinde setzte einen sprecher ein
der fortan alle fragen beantwortete
alle bewohner von bgl praktisch wissen
wäre straffreiheit
die sind total privatpersonen wo es um
honig oder vermögen comes portemonnaie
können wir sind schlicht ohne geld und
ohne die wechselkleidung france
entstanden
natürlich haben sie auch den wohnung
gebracht oder den ordnungs und brauchen
kann schlafen aber die sind wirklich
forum mit stark meinte denn auch sehr
schnell kohl von der soforthilfe zahl
aber mit hilfe der glückskette
nationalrat und das natürlich sehr viel
ausgemacht ich glaube glüht am tal
merken dass der knicks und das gemeint
dass dienst nach vorschrift leisten
flexibel auf die einzelnen schicksale
gott und einer sehr schwer möglich zu
prüfen
szenenwechsel insel gebiet im berner
oberland im juli 2009 passierte in der
gemeinde guttannen ähnliches wie jetzt
in bondo ein ganzer dorfteil drohte für
immer zu verschwinden
[Musik]
auftauen der permafrostböden das gestein
beim ritzlihorn auf 3000 meter über meer
brüchig ein felssturz und heftige
niederschläge lösten gewaltige murgänge
aus groß und brot steiner
bisher war man nicht sieht was ist der
ganz extrem contact steigt und machte
unter chf 128 meter blieb das ist die
vorstufe 5 liter hätten mehrere staaten
das bachbett der aare stieg bedrohlich
an
peter von bergen musste das haus seiner
großmutter im wahrsten sinne des wortes
räumen
zwölf stunden stillstand war in 2011
beide gebäude wurden dem erdboden
gleichgemacht auf befehl der gemeinde
und in absprache mit der
gebäudeversicherung
beinahe hätte von bergen auch noch sein
wohnhaus verloren
quasi über nacht geriet mit den
murgängen rund ein dutzend wohnhäuser in
die gefahrenzone den sogenannten boden
von guttannen wollten die behörden
umsiedeln
morgen ist dass ich meine stimme oder
gehen und der geist ist ein optimist 2
0-heimerfolg sport und 17 jahren und und
der neben israel wieder relativiert dann
istanbul rom und doha of standard ist
einfach total music 3 sie kann also
stellte vor was eigentlich passiert und
ist also im ungewissen amtlich sie
derzeit so verbringen stabilisiert
während die hoffen verbot auf das tempo
wird sie die natur diktierte damals in
guttannen auch das handeln der behörden
die verantwortung lastete auf den
schultern des gemeindepräsidenten dass
die sehkraft und wenn man das als clever
nach alter und sprachen
wenn wir da noch ist wenn man nicht vor
dicht denn dann gehts nimmer dann ist
das ist der unfallzahl und da sollte man
nach din iso hand gehalten erste fasern
und das muss man wird es geht darum das
lied sicher sind
von großflächige umsiedelung spricht
heute in der gemeinde guttannen niemand
mehr
acht jahre nach den murgängen unterhalb
des rittner horns ist die gefahrenkarte
angepasst
nur noch vier wohnhäuser sind in der
gefahrenzone
ich sehe was der gemeindepräsidentin
davor dem vorderrad muss ich sagen die
wahrheit stecken will
die welt war schön dass sie auch genau
mit einer sache messen befassen wir mehr
so vermessen und wenn jetzt das einfach
grad also vom fürsten vermietung szene
kino termindrucks das wahrscheinlich bin
ich ihnen noch schlimmer die schwedin
ist und dass sie völlig zur atom- und
tatsächliche vitaphone um zettel und das
nächste katastrophe
peter von bergen musste nicht umsiedeln
obwohl sein wohnhaus neu in der
gefahrenzone steht wenn aber gefahr
droht müsste er gehen
was jetzt weg an die fans steht zum park
park stets und müssen allein im wagen
liegenden andererseits mäßig zuckersüßer
müssen über ziegen ziehen das nötig ich
zuständig resultate blieben so lange
misshandelt und das geniale daran user
[Musik]
mehr als eine woche ist es her dass
annemieke burgmüller zusammen mit ihrem
mann das haus verlassen musste
die bewohner von gondo haben sich auf
die umliegenden dörfer verteilt kontakt
haben sie nur vereinzelt wenn man jetzt
vor zink sehen jetzt nach paris
die evag flucht sind sozusagen der ufa
wenn man sich begegnet redet man aber
vielleicht auch gar nicht viel und man
fragt er gott was sagen der mit den
augen
also ich weiß es wird gehen wir sohnes
zurückhaltend
zuerst war der schock dann kam die lehre
das eigene haus ist nur einen steinwurf
entfernt
die rückkehr in das in weiter ferne von
normalität kann freilich keine rede sein
und doch bemühen sich alle um eine art
geordneten alltag im exil mit schweizer
grenze wo kaffee trinke und wieder zog
und stundenlang schwester also
eigentlich ist das auch nötig oder ich
ja
bedürfnisse oder auch für andere blüten
ich sehe die religion sprung auf italien
vize coo es sogar schwierig da im orbit
einfach ruhig zu
denn ich wäre einfacher musik und
genomik weg für mich sind eine oft
musste also obwohl soll die winterheide
eigene jährigen aus zu hause könnten
also sender erreichte innerhalb
kürzester zeit die nationale politik
bundespräsidentin doris leuthard wollte
sich persönlich ein bild der verwüstung
machen welche die naturgewalt im bergell
angerichtet hatte
fest jetzt weitergehen mit solchen
zwischenfällen gewissen und das ist ja
nicht das erste mal dass ich das sage
ich ja froh permafrost murgänge
klimawandel
es ist eine realität etwa finale geht es
immer noch nicht behalten diese aussage
der bundespräsidentin sorgte in manchen
kreisen für aufregung
tatsächlich beschäftigen sich auch die
experten intensiv mit der frage ob
feldberg stürzte eine direkte folge des
schwinden permafrost sind verursacht
durch den klimawandel
einer dieser experten ist nils hählen
leiter der abteilung naturgefahren des
bayerischen amtes für wald reporter
begleitet ihn auf den wild strubel auf
3243 meter über meer gut sonst lachen
port temperaturfühler daran dass sie und
die masse kontinuierlich temperatur das
geht darum dass die antwort aber man
kann oft schon wurde dass man nachher
gesagt die temperatur über jahresverlauf
aber als roman wick und nils hählen hat
in einer studie in den berner alpen
untersucht welche auswirkungen der
schwindende permafrost und der rückgang
der gletscher auf die stabilität der
berge haben generell dafür eigens eine
häufige der welt und deshalb vor allem
interessiert gibt es irgendwelche
gebiert warum man den akzent das akute
problem räume im zusammenhang mit der
sich liegen also dass plötzlich der
eigene innere größter intensität teams
die hütten nieder roden eh nix kapiert
und die frage eigentlich momentan nicht
absehbar ist es geht wohl häufig
verhältnis aber meistens sieht ford von
einem woody ereignis stattfinden das
essen in der direktive wirklichkeit was
sehr schwierig ist berechtigt von
prozessen aber wie jetzt das ist im fall
wunder passiert ist ein bergsturz da ich
mit gut verträglicher nach derzeitigen
gemacht aber mit einer usk hat die jetzt
von bmw tätig schaffen und
heutige freitag vorstellen und der
prognose zu machen das ist schäbig und
das sieht die große unsere kreiert aber
unser studio neue anderen und das übrige
drinnen dass sie also darum hast
trotzdem überrascht dass solche
überraschungen wie in bondo
siedlungsgebiete gefährden mag die
ausnahme bleiben michael kirchner ist
sich bewusst dass es in den alpinen
tourismusgebieten anders aussieht acht
bergwanderer kamen am cembalo ums leben
[Musik]
riesig
natürlich hofft kirchner das schon bald
wieder die schönheit der region im
vordergrund stehen wird
vorbei am katastrophengebiet fahren wir
ins höher gelegenes olio dem
panoramablick konnte der bergsturz kaum
etwas anhaben und davor da ist natürlich
sollte man wirklich nicht viel material
metall liegt für die parameter aber viel
mehr gesetzt von der niederlassung auto
bike selber gesehen nicht wirklich
anders aus aber kläglich zum ganzer berg
mit ihm über dauer ich habe nichts
gefühlt man sieht was gefährlich in dem
eigentlich wollte ich einfach wahrnehmen
wo halt jetzt halt media einfach so nach
außen gesendet worden ist oder aber das
projekt 51 prozent von jährlich sicht
hatte und der mädels in oderberg leicht
nur stunden später in der nacht vom 31
august auf den ersten september
erreichte erneut eine große mure die
bälle talsohle bei mondo weitere häuser
wurden zerstört straßen verschüttet
es kam zu stromausfällen wer nicht
selber fliehen konnte wurde mit dem
helikopter evakuiert
die kantonsstrasse richtung maloja wurde
auf mehreren abschnitten verschüttet das
bergell war nun weder von norden noch
von süden her erreichbar
an diesen tristen erster septembertag
hätte man leicht denken können nicht nur
die bewohner hätten bondo verlassen
sondern mit ihnen auch alle guten
geister
wenn geht es wieder das normales leben
im brutto ich glaubs leber wird nich so
symbolisch will es wird vermutlich das
weiß man noch nicht sicher wo vermutlich
niemand davon gebaut werde daran dass
hinter gibt es bereichs autobahn das
historische wunder wo sie vor der
herzigen betroffen sind im moment kann
man dabei bediene will will alle zur
vater sind sind momentan beschädigt und
es ist es ist schwierig wie das aussah
wie das leben in bonn den späteren
sieger da wird es müsse für reto müller
ist an eine rückkehr in sein haus nicht
zu denken
egal was die experten meinen werden ihm
wäre es am liebsten wenn er enteignet
würde und irgendwo noch mal neu anfangen
könnte also der kanton sollte man
schnell entscheide sich entscheiden sich
die häuser hinweg und mag irgendwie
anders
aufbau und abzog und sauer oder
besonders für familien mit zwei kindern
die die grüße euch vor wir sind schon
älter und
seine frau tut sich schwerer mit dem
gedanken loszulassen
sie müsse zuerst einmal die gefühle
ordnen zu verstehen versuchen erst dann
könne sie sich überlegungen zur zukunft
machen aber jetzt schon gedanken gemacht
nach für die in einem dorf übrigen
bewohner stahlwelle bliebe das ist sohn
ist wunderschön stahel mit nur zwei wege
machen auch zum labour ich leben
die römer schafften das tal einst
regalia vor gallien vielleicht kein
zufall dass den menschen hier heute noch
etwas unerschütterliches eigen ist
[Musik]